they have announced the GOP an
impeachment inquiry is about to begin so
this means the Republicans will begin to
ask the question of whether or not we
should impeach Joe Biden I know I've
ragged on the Republicans quite a bit
for this like just vote to impeach
however I don't want to get ahead of
myself I actually think this might be as
much as I want more direct action and
they can do other things this is
probably the right path to go they're
going to now have committee hearings
they're going to have more or they
should supposedly not enact more
subpoena power and then put together all
of these uh different documents and
different bits of evidence and then have
a formal vote I can respect that I think
the strategy here is to launch the uh
the impeachment proceedings and have the
inquiry throughout the election year
makes sense I guess I'd prefer not to be
political based on my principles I'd say
we have more than enough evidence to
impeach the guy but the corporate press
of course is lying about everything and
oh we're gonna call them out for it in
other big news oh and shroyers here and
uh he's going to jail oh and Owen's
going to prison and uh
document right here it is uh I think
it's egregious I think it's obvious that
they're targeting Owen over his
political speech and the document backs
this up we talked about it quite a bit
over the past few days but now with the
sentence officially coming in at 60 days
I I think when you look at the story it
is it is beyond a reasonable doubt the
courts are trying to silence uh
political speech as we've seen with a
bunch of these different prosecutions so
we're going to talk about that and a
bunch of other stories of course before
we do it my friends head over to
timcast.com and click
timcast irlx Miami to pick up your
tickets to our Miami event we're going
to be there October 6th 6 p.m at 10 30
p.m we got Patrick met David Donald
Trump Jr Matt Gates me and Lou
gradkowski plus Ian will be there it's
going to be a it's gonna be a blast we
actually have a bunch of other people
who are showing up to hang out so you
may see people that uh you're a big fan
of I'm not going to say who say who once
we get a definitive list of special
guests who will be hanging out and
they're cool with it we'll we'll
announce that as well but there's a
bunch of really cool people who are
showing up so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends click join us and
become a member at timcast.com to watch
the uncensored show tonight which I
imagine is going to be a whole lot of
fun and I hereby revoke authorization to
timcast.com to any federal agent of the
government and if you do access my
servers that will be in violation of the
cfaa
okay I'm kidding you guys can watch fine
whatever okay but joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more we
have Monica Crowley hi I'm it's so good
to be here thank you so much for having
me oh thanks for coming do you want to
introduce yourself yeah no it's it's
great so I have been very honored to
work for not one but two American
Presidents Richard Nixon during his last
years and president Trump as assistant
Secretary of the Treasury and I always
like to joke man do I know how to pick
him or what only the most controversial
presidents for me okay uh no Grover
Cleveland's for Monica a long media
career New York Times best-selling
author and now the host of the Monica
Crowley podcast wow this is awesome it's
great to have you and uh you know you
were telling us just before the show
about talking with Trump about what he
didn't realize coming into the
presidency so I definitely think we'll
get into all that stuff as we talk about
impeachment and Trump 2024 but should be
fun thanks for hanging out great and oh
and Shroyer was in town so we uh we we
forced him to come here well the Stars
aligned perfectly for me to make the
first appearance on Tim cast tonight uh
Tim and his crew put forth a lot of
effort to make sure this happened I'm
pretty much gonna go two or three days
without sleep but when you're at War for
the country and Free Speech I guess that
that's what it takes so glad to be here
tonight and I know we got a lot of
exciting things and important things to
talk about right on thanks for coming
hello I am Phil Labonte I'm the lead
singer of all the remains anti-communist
and counter-revolutionary I'm extremely
excited to be here tonight to talk to
Owen and Monica thank you guys and
yes I'm sitting here too it's a pleasure
to meet you man uh yourself with Monica
uh let's just jump into it here's the
big news for the for the day we got this
from The New York Times and I love the
way they headlined this McCarthy facing
an ouster and a shutdown orders and
impeachment inquiry I just want to pause
real quick because the news is McCarthy
actually made a very succinct and
precise statement about why there should
be an inquiry into the uh potential High
crimes and misdemeanors abusive power of
President Joe Biden I was actually
fairly impressed and uh for no reason
the New York Times includes this this
additional information notice the commas
how about a headline that says McCarthy
orders an impeachment inquiry and
nothing else yeah that's the appropriate
news headline but of course they want to
add nonsensical context to alter your
perception on what is actually happening
they're trying to make it seem like
there's no evidence they're trying to
make it seem like he's only doing this
because he's facing serious pressure but
the reality is we have the evidence most
of you have already seen it we'll go
over a lot of it and talk about it but
here's the news from The New York Times
They say
McCarthy's decision to unilaterally
announce an impeachment investigation
with no formal house vote entwined the
Republican investigations into Mr Biden
with the funding fight that is rattling
the capital it appeared to be a bid to
quell a brewing Rebellion among
ultra-conservative critics who have
accused the speaker of not taking a hard
enough line on spending blah blah blah I
just gotta say
look we're at the point where people
have access to information outside of
these corporate sources and I do think
when you look at even CNN's polling on
this they found 55 percent of people
believe that Joe Biden was behaving
inappropriately as it pertained to
barisma and the you know withholding
money people are waking up to what's
going on so Joe Biden should be
impeached he should have been impeached
he should he never should have been
elected in my opinion but if he gets
elected because people voted to elect
them fine but I actually think Joe Biden
should have been convicted of criminal
offenses before he even got into office
granted maybe we didn't know enough fine
but when Trump started to look into
these crimes what happens they impeach
him curious what you guys think yeah no
it a hundred percent and the the line
now it was trending all day on Twitter
the phrase without evidence so they've
all gotten their marching orders now
that this is how they're going to cast
this process that it's illegitimate you
know they've gone after Donald Trump
they've gone after all of us for being
illegitimate illegitimate voters
illegitimate president actually Joe
Biden button is the actual illegitimate
president but this is how they go and
the marching orders have gone out that
there is no evidence there are mountains
of evidence uh this man not just from
when he was vice president but from he
when he was a sitting U.S senator all
the way through the vice presidency and
you know what guys nobody is talking
about what he might be doing now I mean
he is the sitting president of the
United States and nobody is talking
about what he could be doing now you
know also tease out the other point
about this people have been so focused
on the fact that he's gotten a ton of
money tens of millions of dollars
enriching himself and his family by
using Hunter Biden as The Bag Man but
nobody takes it to the next logical
point which is the reason that we're
going to have this impeachment which is
that Joe Biden took these tens of
millions of dollars to change American
policy that so that is the two direct
things that the founders actually put in
the institution defined for impeachment
bribery and treason and other crimes and
misdemeanors but if we can prove and I
think we certainly can because we have
tons of evidence here that he engaged in
both actions this man needs to be
removed from office like yesterday I
have a question for you for you then
what do you think happens
should there be an impeachment right the
house finds him finds that there is an
impeachment that needs to happen goes to
the Senate and the Senate finds him not
guilty because it is going to find him
not guilty because we don't control that
body so so they're gonna you know quit
him on that and he will continue
Assuming he's able to physically but
that's not really the point right the
point like the Democrats did with Trump
Democrats with Trump had no evidence
Trump did nothing wrong they ran through
two fake impeachments without a vote
these are the new rules now right yeah
so now we're going to follow those rules
and all of a sudden the Democrats have a
huge problem with it but the point is to
air out all of this evidence regardless
of how it ends in the Senate you go and
do the right thing the house has all of
this evidence impeach the man have it as
part of the historical record get all of
the evidence on the record and then
allow the American people to see it just
one thing I don't I know I don't want to
come off like I was saying that I or I
don't want to give you the impression
that I was that I'm against the idea
because that's not the case at all but
my concern is I feel like you're correct
about the evidence is it's overwhelming
it is clear that Hunter Biden was a Bag
Man it is clear that he was giving him
money to his father because of the
things that his father could do I don't
see a whole lot of a whole lot of room
wiggle room in in the in when you
present the evidence just the stuff that
I've seen personally
um
that being said
like what does that say for the U.S like
the Donald Trump stuff what everyone
knew that it was kind of a hack right it
was just a garbage job because they
didn't like him and it wasn't actually
that he did significant things the idea
of Hunter Biden having receipts of
actual uh wire transfers actually
sending money to his his dad and all the
stuff of the emails saying he's doing it
100 so when it comes out and then they
it like when that comes out and then we
have a situation where he does not get
found guilty because that's what I
strongly believe wouldn't happen what
does that say for the countries and I'm
looking for more of an opinion than an
actual you know let it be said it says a
lot it's look with the the indictments
of Donald Trump with everything we're
seeing in the January 6 case and
everything we don't see with the Riots
of the White House on May 29th or the
riots in DC on January 20th 2017. I
think everyone understands and there was
a uh I can't remember the order in which
the pundits said this but for first it
was that there is a two-tier justice
system that there's you know for the
left and the right and then someone
doesn't make injectable because that's
actually three tier it's if you're a
regular person they don't care about you
they might just throw you away throw you
you know throw you in the jail ignore
you it's you're nothing if you're a
privileged Elite establishment you get
protection and ignored and if you're a
trump supporter now they're gonna throw
the book at you every chance they get
well there was one person that called
out the phony Trump impeachment right to
their face and I think the government is
still pursuing legal action against that
individual he may or may not be on this
show right now in a purple shirt but you
know Monica you might want to watch your
step uh saying Joe Biden is
illegitimately elected might be a
criminal offense now so we've got to be
we've got to be very careful well look
we all know as you said Tim that these
establishment corporate Rags always want
to deflect with the headline and they're
well aware that most people don't read
past the headline and so if they can try
to manipulate your Viewpoint via uh
distractive headline or a deceiving
headline then we know they're going to
do that but I think in this case whether
intentionally or not the New York Times
is actually right I think Kevin McCarthy
knows that Republican voters are sick of
him I think Kevin McCarthy knows that
the House Republicans specifically out
of the freedom caucus are sick of him
you know this is a guy that fought tooth
and nail to be the speaker I mean he sat
up there and took the slings and arrows
because he wanted to be the speaker he
made a bunch of promises to House
Republicans and Republican voters and he
hasn't delivered on any of them and so
right now Matt Gates is putting the heat
on speaker McCarthy and I actually think
that I actually think the New York Times
is right I think Kevin McCarthy knows
that if he doesn't do something even if
it's just lip service then Republican
voters and Republicans in the house are
going to realize this guy's an empty
suit I'm afraid of the lip service no
not because not because like there's
some kind of negative repercussions from
the services I'm just so tired of
ineffective and like you know
incompetent Republicans not doing things
not using being in positions of power
and not using power the Democrats have
no issue no hesitation exercising power
when they get into I would say abusing
power fair enough fair enough
um and Republicans are terrified of it
they're afraid of being called names
because they're more comfortable in the
minority right I mean they like being
sort of on defense and they can
fundraise off of it they're more
comfortable in those positions but why
is Matt Gates the only member of
Congress who took to the floor today as
far as I saw and delivered a barn burner
of a speech against Kevin McCarthy look
we are in a war for the future of the
country we can't have these weak need
Republicans just being the loyal
opposition anymore and the base gets it
I think a growing number of the American
people understand that the hour is very
late in the country we're at a Tipping
Point here we've been under assault by
these globalists but certainly by the
the global Marxist Revolution for almost
a century starting in the 1930s and
they've been chipping away at our
constitution that's what I'm talking
about let's cut to the core I've been
talking about a long time okay and we
are now at the Tipping Point and there's
no more we wait to quote the Predator
movie we ain't got time to bleed that's
right okay and so if you're in a
position of authority in the GOP or or
any place in this movement and you don't
get it or you're in on it with the other
side you gotta go we gotta bounce you
and that includes the speaker of the
house if necessary no more no more
political no more political clubs right
and that seems that seems to be the case
in D.C everybody wants to be in the club
and they want to get along and they
don't want whether it's a Democrat or
Republican kind of looking at them with
the stink eye when they show up at the
parties or when they show up in the
Hamptons and even more to Matt Gage
credit you know last week he actually
gave himself a bit of a tongue lashing
when he came out and he said you know
what I haven't done enough you're right
I haven't done enough I need to do more
and he comes out and he gives that
speech today and I think that's I really
do believe that's why Kevin McCarthy he
knows that he can't win in the Senate he
knows he can't win in the Senate why
would McCarthy be doing this now what
new evidence is there against Joe and
Hunter Biden that we haven't had for
years we've had the evidence for years
what is he sitting on they're waiting
for the election I I think that's the
only thing that makes sense if they
launch all of this stuff right away 20
you know as soon as they they take they
take the house then they they fire off
their shot and that's it I think if you
look at why they're not I mean look for
you it's been two and a half years and
now all of a sudden they're bringing
this case up it's hitting the news the
the Democrats know the game they're
playing as well wait until 2024 to start
making big arrests rating houses
arresting people targeting Trump
I think McCarthy is probably alike for
one obviously too many of the Democrats
just roll over and let things their
Democrats go on the speed Republicans Or
democrats go on the speed limit but I
think a lot of this might be if we do
act too quickly then we fizzle out too
quickly and so a slow build up might
actually work better politically let's
get a little wonky with this what would
the political strategy be than heading
into 2024 because at this point I don't
see why the Republicans wouldn't want
Joe Biden to run right I mean you have
all the dirt on him he's not just not
popular he's unpopular yeah even
Democrat voters the vast majority say
we'll take anyone but Biden give me a
ham sandwich and I'll take that over Joe
Biden so to me if you're the Republicans
you want Joe Biden to run he can't he
can't even campaign and now you're
dealing with a situation Cornell West is
going to take votes away from the
Democrat base if Robert F Kennedy Jr
who's calling out the corrupt process
within the Democrat Party decides to run
third party that's going to take even
more votes away from the Democrats now
unfortunately they can't rally behind
Donald Trump but we can get over that as
Republican voters or even independent
voters that are going to vote for Trump
now I just don't even think it's a good
political strategy to me
I say let Joe Biden run make him
campaign that's all I want but they're
not going to convict him so they're
trying to taint as much of his
presidency in his campaign as possible
and get it on the historical record too
I think a couple of points about this I
think Republicans are always so careful
as they should be because propaganda
press will you know rip them apart if
they don't go about this the right way
so they are trying to build a case
unlike the Democrats with Trump who just
went in and railroaded him and they
continue to try to Railroad him and they
don't have any facts and it doesn't
matter right
um so I do think they're trying to build
a case the other thing is when I was
flying here today uh guys from New York
on my plane behind me was a republican
member of Congress who shall go nameless
and this uh member of Congress
recognized me I recognized them and this
person is sort of establishment sort of
established I wouldn't say swamp but
sort of establishment trying to like
we de-board the plane and I went up to
this member and this member recognized
me and we start talking and I I said
I said I I understand that you were
um trending on Twitter today you
probably guess who it might be but in
any case we had a conversation about the
impeachment and this member of Congress
uh indicated that at least they would
like to see the impeachment done for
sure but wrapped up by like December
31st so they don't want to drag it
through an election year because at
least the establishment members don't
want it to flick back on them right like
they don't want the blowback they think
the Press is going to jump all over them
with this illegitimate impeachment and
so on so they want a lot of time and
distance between the end of the
impeachment no conviction in the Senate
but an impeachment an election day in
November at least that seemed to be the
establishment point of view
let's ask John fetterman what he thinks
of this impeachment in this video that's
going tremendously viral
McCarthy has formally launched an
impeachment has said he's going to oh my
God we oh my gosh you know oh it's
devastating
oh don't do it please don't do it oh no
oh no
I got I gotta be honest while I see a
lot of people on the right sharing this
video being shocked that fetterman had
this reaction to it that's going to work
a really really well for the leftist
base for the leftist populists they're
gonna look at that as that the reason
why they like fetterman and they
obviously Democrats don't want his his
uh his stroke right his his uh his
Affliction or who knows what yeah I mean
right right and but they also want to
downplay that they want to they want to
play up don't acute don't attack someone
who's suffering a medical issue and
things like that but the reason they
like the guy is that they're trying to
be like Trump they know that Trump is
reaching out to these middle American
working class Union guys that see that
that like more of what he does well I'll
put it this way if you're a dude hanging
out at a hang out with by the grill with
your buddies in the backyard having a
beer you are closer to Trump I know it
sounds shocking than you are Joe Biden
Joe Biden is so far removed with his
Rehoboth Beach Delaware upbringing and
whatever he was doing I don't know
riding horses and sing at the pool
having kids stroke his legs Donald Trump
while born rich and and wealthy and all
that is closer I'm not saying he's close
but he's closer to to a dude who would
hang out and have a beer with you they
need fetterman and they need this kind
of behavior that comes off as as like
more down to earth well and you just saw
Trump at the Iowa football game Iowa for
Cyrus State I mean he was like he fit
right in it was like he was the
grandfather of The Godfather of the
fraternity I mean well done steak with
ketchup yeah I mean he held the burger
up for everybody to see but you know
let's be clear why that resonates with
democrats for the same reason when
Donald Trump hoists a hamburger in the
air or says that he wants to have a
retribution to her that resonates with
his voters that behavior from fetterman
resonates with Democrat voters you can
you can show a Democrat all the videos
of Joe Biden literally grabbing children
on C-Span grabbing their crotches
stroking their hair yeah that's your
response you show that to a Democrat oh
no no dude when we when we have liberal
voters in here and actually you guys
have seen the video of the pot there's a
radio host asking the journalist about
Hunter Biden and the and the uh uh
corruption the journalist is like I
don't know you're talking about he's
like Hunter Biden said my dad takes my
salary and he goes I don't know about
that it's like that was uh Philip yeah
the Washington Post Yeah that's supposed
to be someone that's serious walks off
the set yes so when we have these people
on liberal voters and they come on
rarely and they make it like how come
you won't have us on Tim I'm like bro
y'all are always invited you just don't
show up when I when I pull up an article
and I'm like here's an article that says
Hunter Biden contacted DC to get
prosecutor fired they go that's a
conspiracy theory Washington Post no I'm
like this is this is the New York Times
here here's the New York Times saying
Merrick Garland was pressured by the
White House to prosecute Donald Trump
specifically because Joe Biden told his
staff he wanted it done and they're like
that's a conspiracy here's the text
here's the email sometimes literally you
have his laptop I have his text do I I
don't have the New York Times propaganda
works oh here we go very well if the New
York Times pulled up the New York Times
Jesus darling faces growing pressure as
January 6 investigation widens hey you
don't like the New York Times I'm not
the biggest fan either but they outright
say in this let me uh is this one right
here here we go the Attorney General's
deliberative approach blah blah has come
to frustrate Democrat allies of the
White House and at times Biden himself
as recently as late last year Biden
confided to his inner circle that he
believed Trump was a threat to democracy
and should be prosecuted according to
two people familiar with the comment it
goes on to say that Joe Biden has
privately said he wanted Garland to act
less like a ponderous judge and more
like a prosecutor who was willing to
take decisive action over the events of
January 6. so when you have Joe Biden
saying to his staff I want Trump
prosecuted why won't Merrick Garland be
more decisive you think Merrick Garland
doesn't get to get the message so when
we're talking about who should be
impeached if if your argument is to me
and this is what they say they come on
the show and they're like Donald Trump
was digging up Turner's political
opponent and I'm like Joe Biden ordered
the prosecution of his political
opponent that's a conspiracy theory no
it's in the New York Times doesn't
matter they don't care well you had the
one lady from New York who ran her
campaign on I'm gonna get Donald Trump
that was her entire campaign and she got
elected and then uh I I don't know what
I think she she was the one that ended
up indicting him out of New York her
campaign was elect me all indict Trump
wasn't funny what else to say the same
thing
Leticia James yeah that's the one yeah
but look the left gets away with this
James came after us at Infowars and Alex
Jones too yeah that's right that's New
York yeah how defamation or something
look I don't know if I'm I don't know if
I'm at Liberty to discuss this but let's
just say Leticia James did everything
she could to try to hurt Alex Jones in
Infowars of course that's crazy man but
look the left gets away with this
because number one they control
everything now Long March through the
institutions over many decades and
number two they've got the protection of
the press so when you have the
protection of the press you can
literally get away with anything
including murder I agree but I think
we're winning and I think you look at
the the math and the economics of the
matter you look at Target they're stock
dropping Bud Light dropping you look at
uh uh Disney and Netflix losing
subscribers you look at a sound of
Freedom Richmond North or Richmond you
look at even Yingling getting support
any anyone other than Bud Light those
those numbers mean more uh uh than and
those are hard numbers you just talked
about a new beer that's about to come
out oh no this is that already we have
some conservative dads Ultra right beer
Seth weathers and that's good apparel
because people want to support something
that isn't Global you know globalist
corporate propaganda right you have uh
apparently now they're they're shipping
them by by the truckload by Massive
semisfold they're they're selling so
much of this beer and uh I mean
everyone's launching their own thing
when Aunt Jemima gets pulled from the
brand Terence Williams says screw that
and he makes a replacement and I I I
what it's one of the coolest things ever
they removed Aunt Jemima from the
pancake things and it is one of the most
shockingly offensive things ever to me
that they were like oh you can't have a
black woman on on a pancake box and I'm
like what why like the most popular
pancakes of all time of all time get rid
of her so Terence Williams has I'm gonna
put my face on the box then and I'll and
and I'll say that I say okay I'm gonna
buy from him regretted I don't need a
lot of Pancakes you know too much sugar
right I cut that out but we have a bunch
of cousin tees right now and
it's it's these woke companies need to
be told and they're told simply by not
buying their products so while we can
look at the political stuff that's going
on I think what they're doing to you
Owen I think we're doing the j6ers I
think what they're doing to Trump shows
how panicked and desperate they are New
Mexico shows how panicked and desperate
they are they have been trying to ban
guns for how long but if you look at the
list of states that are going
constitutional carry more than half the
country I think we're like 26 or 27
States now so what is the panicked and
desperate Democrat Governor do decree I
hereby decree and what happens people
walk outside with their guns say nope
it's not working so what what are they
going to do well when a person is
drowning they thrash about violently and
as they start to lose power which is
clear from 2016. Hillary Clinton wasn't
supposed to lose the fact that she did
show is the establishment power is
waning these corrupt establishment
shells inherited a machine they did not
know how to operate and they are losing
control of it and the people are
starting to take control back they're
freaking out because of it and they're
gonna get it's gonna get nasty but in
the end I think we win and that's why I
keep telling everybody people say the
stuff like you know they're talking
about what do we do now to resist I'm
like it's really really simple you knock
on doors you get the word out you only
buy products from companies that support
your values and you vote for Donald
Trump in 2020. and think about how
politicians and even people in the
political realm operate right it's all
about votes or popularity and so when
the New Mexico Governor comes out and
makes maybe the most anti-second
Amendment decision or decree of all time
what happens far left Democrat Ted Liu
has to disavow it David Hall the most
anti-second Amendment activists out
there has to disavow it so even they
know like hey we better not get go along
with this because this is not popular
right now it's it's I everything we're
seeing is acts of desperation but I
wanna I wanna clarify because people
keep saying like how could they have
control of the institutions but we be
winning because let's say that they have
70 percent of institutional power and in
six months they'll have
67 that means we are winning they are
being pushed back and pushed out of
these institutions for too long most
people have set back set by and let them
do these things and even during the you
know the uh I don't say the peak but
even in the in the trenches of the
culture war in say 2018-19 with Trump
and russiagate people were not doing
these boycotts or boycotts and in fact I
was kind of like I don't know it seems
weird to me I don't want to be like that
now we're at the point where we're
creating our own chocolate well daily
wire has their own chocolate brand and
it's got better ingredients the the
daily Jeremy's chocolate has like four
ingredients at no preservative garbage
it's like cocoa cocoa butter sugar and
milk or something isn't that part of the
populist movement too it's not just a
political thing it's even a health thing
yeah you know there's there's oil to it
seed oils all this other stuff but you
know here's an interesting phenomenon
that has been happening really I would
say Post Obama more than anything maybe
it's liberals being anti-war to being
pro-war but even that's a little more
nuanced here's here's something that's
direct and right in your face
it used to be that the First Amendment
and the Second Amendment were huge
liberal causes liberals were always
going to go to bat for the First
Amendment liberals were always going to
go to bat for the Second Amendment where
that's not a liberal belief anymore now
if you want to be a modern day American
liberal Progressive Democrat your
anti-free speech your anti-second
amendment I mean that's that's been the
phenomenon that we've witnessed it's a
complete inversion right what we've seen
over the last like two decades since a
complete inversion because what you're
describing Owen is Classical liberalism
small L liberalism right what we have
now is a wholesale takeover of the
Democratic Party by the marxists by the
Communists and they call themselves
Progressive because they call themselves
progressives because it's a it's it's a
subversive ideology sorry which is
another inverse because they're really
regressing exactly that's exactly right
and I have always said that communism
Never Dies it just gets rebranded yeah
so what you have now is a rebranding of
Communism to make it sound sort of 21st
century and and hip and something that's
going to attract younger voters Etc and
it has been working but Tim to your
point you know conservatives for a long
time were anti-boycott oh we can't do it
because they'll do it to us and we're
better than that and all of that moral
superiority nonsense right but now we
are starting to feel our own power
because so many of us realize we're at a
Tipping Point and there is no
alternative other than losing our
country so we're willing to put our
disposable income where it counts and
it's all organic it's not like the left
you know doing their their you know
astroturfing nonsense wait you mean they
don't actually like Dylan Mulvaney come
on but it's actually organic right so so
what we've seen with Disney with Target
with a whole range of companies now has
been an organic Choice by millions of us
to say we're going to put our money our
mouth is now and we're going to make a
proactive choice this is a point that
I've made a couple times and I
completely agree with you there is an
inherent vulnerability in liberalism and
that's that liberals listen to their
opponents and or their their they
believe that open dialogue is important
you believe in the first amendment that
means you have to hear the opponents out
people that you're arguing with people
on the left
people that are not liberals they do not
have the desire file you mean like
classical and philosophical liberal yes
when I'm talking about liberals I'm
talking about classical liberals when
I'm talking about people that they don't
agree with when I talk about
progressives I'm talking about people
that don't have an Enlightenment uh
doesn't don't have any respect for the
enlightenment they don't believe that
you can actually come to an agreement
based on truth and honesty they believe
that that it's all about perspective and
and so it all boils down to power and
you have to have you have to have
liberals understand that when you're
dealing with people that don't respect
things like honesty that don't respect
uh the the freedom of speech because
they don't believe that there is a
freedom they don't believe that there is
a truth so if these people are
approaching it without a respect for
honesty and and open dialogue and stuff
They're all playing a power game I think
that the classical liberals in the US
have finally started to realize that
that inherent vulnerability is there and
so you can be liberal with other
liberals and and approach other liberals
and expect an honest dialogue but you
have to first ascertain if they're
actually liberals if they're commies
they're God they're gonna lie to you
commies always lie I think one of the
big turning points for conservatives was
that you know for the longest time uh
like you were pointing this out oh and
liberals actually defended the First
Amendment but something happened to the
modern left we used to say that
Democrats were left and Republicans were
right we still kind of say that but now
there's leftists and if you look at that
Pew research which is really interesting
it shows that the the GOP in this
country moves like one degree to the
right and the left goes like four
degrees to the left so what happens is
people like me I'm like moderate
moderate fairly independent slightly
left-wing a lot of issues but I believe
in the Constitution I believe in the
constitutional republic I believe in
free speech Common Sense common sense I
care about what's true or not so while
you know a few years ago my attitude on
guns was like well there's probably some
reasonable things I don't want to
infringe on anyone's rights but I think
we can come to some reasonable
conclusions on how we can make things
better and safer and then I had some
logical arguments with people who are
more alerted than I and I said that is
the correct uh moral approach and that
is while I certainly think people
shouldn't have nuclear weapons as long
as the Constitution protects the right
to do so we have to agree on our uh uh
based on our rules of how we live in a
society to change the Constitution
before we can restrict people's rights
they don't do that my point is
over time
I'm in a position where I'm like you
know I grew up pro-choice that within a
certain amount of time women can can
deal with their health care their their
bodies that means that there's going to
be bad things that happen elective
abortion I think is horrible but it
means there's gonna be women suffering
from very serious afflictions and they
need to go to their doctor and the
having paperwork and submitting approval
and stuff is kind of scary but what
happens now
now we get Democrats who are just saying
you can abort a baby at any time for no
reason at all and I'm like well that's
completely psychotic I used to be with
the Democrats on their positions but
they decided to be Psychopaths now you
get more disaffected liberals defective
defected liberals standing with
conservatives which means people who
used to work in entertainment rock stars
musicians actors people who used to be
entrenched in Democrat politics being
like they've gone nuts I'm out all that
creativity and cultural influence starts
bleeding into the right where we used to
make fun of these like religious and
conservative attempts at making films or
movies you know like everyone jokes
about Bible men and stuff like that you
now have Angel Studios making amazing
movies so you you've got uh obviously
sound of Freedom was awesome and it's a
good message but now they've got uh I'm
blanking on the name of that that new
movie that's coming out soon do you guys
know the about the nun in in Brooklyn oh
yeah I can't think of the name of
but they've got a bunch of trails coming
out Angel Studios is skyrocketing well
and now Mark Wahlberg and Mel Gibson
want to set up new studios in Nevada
which is actually a big buzz right now
in Nevada a lot of people are talking
about that but what you're what you're
getting into now is results of policy
right so if we look at the results of
policy what have we seen most recently
let's just look at one issue
specifically with illegal immigration
well all of these cities run by
democrats that embraced this idea this
concept never seen or heard of before
Sanctuary cities well what are they all
doing now now Democrat voters are in the
streets they're protesting the illegal
immigrants and so oh look we we're a
sanctuary City we want all the illegal
immigrants but damn it get them out of
here send them back to Texas so so now
let's look at let's look at what the
results of let's say if they get their
their pipe dream of disarming American
citizens well what are you going to have
the criminals are going to run the city
all the criminals are going to have the
guns and the law-abiding citizens are
going to be disarmed well what are they
going to do then well they're going to
protest during coven this is this is
this is hilarious and and the riots that
erupted
you had out of Southern California lines
out the door to gun shops and there was
a guy a gun store owner who made a video
saying y'all come into my store yelling
at me that you can't buy a gun today
because you voted for this stop telling
me I have I can't do it and it's really
really funny they rushed to buy guns
when the riots erupted and then they
crashed headfirst into the policies they
voted for well you know but this gets to
a bigger point there are so many
Democrat voters out there who do not
connect their vote with the consequences
of their vote okay so like if you grow
up in a deep blue area like New York
City and your parents vote Democrats so
you vote Democrat or you're culturally
Democrat or however you describe
yourself and then you just like an
automaton like robotically just vote for
the same thing but then wonder why your
city is going to hell in a handbasket
why you can't walk down the street
without fear of being mugged they don't
connect and you know I have ton of
democratic friends who live in New York
City and they're like complaining
Non-Stop about Adams and Biden and
illegal immigrants all over the place
and the clouds of pot smoke on the
street
and when I say okay so you're going to
vote Republican next time right you're
going to vote for Trump or you're going
to vote they're like oh no I would never
vote for John so stop complaining then
but you're also with your ignorance
inflicting all of this on the rest of us
quite literally took a dump on their own
floor and then complained it was there
and it's yours yes
it's like that one meme with Eric Andre
shooting the guy and saying why would
you do this yeah but you know I think it
was Michael Savage in the 90s that
coined the phrase liberalism as a mental
disorder right and it's really just been
kind of it's really just been kind of a
a cliche or a catchphrase for for a
decade or two but now I think we can
really analyze this and understand it
and you just started to hit on it and um
psychology has always been a big
interest of mine I studied it in college
and what we're dealing with here is this
is the mental disorder now as modern day
liberalism I I literally think they
cannot attribute action to consequence I
mean I I literally think there's
something wrong it's like well it's like
if you're playing yes and you move the
pawn and then the guy makes Checkmate
it's like oh how did you do that what
but it was like they literally cannot
think one step ahead I literally think
there's something wrong but but
I guess the challenge is it's not a
disorder it's just that some people
don't have the ability to see as far as
some people and so a natural sorting
algorithm occurs some like look people
are stupid people are average people are
smart what I think you end up seeing is
why is it that the Republican policies
and not all of them because the
Republican party I think is is very you
know Placid and weak but uh the
discussion tends to be very I don't know
mature serious it's not always because
it's not absolutely what I'm saying but
there's a lot of look I'd like to fund
Healthcare but let's talk about where
the money comes from if we're going to
fund this through this way what do we
get on the left they just say what do
you mean just do it just do it AOC says
deficit spend it's like they say just
spend the money I'll give you an example
uh up to your point Owen I was arguing
with some socialists on Twitter because
it's fun to do yes and uh this was this
was during like the 2020 primary or
whatever I was a big fan of Yang and
Tulsi gabbard and I was wrong with the
socialists and we got to the discussion
of you know they wanted a socialist
Utopia and I said okay let's start from
the beginning where does food come from
like the the basic resource a human
needs to survive and they said the store
wasn't AOC on tape like oh my gosh it
grows from the ground is that did she I
don't know no that looked that up
cauliflower she loved cauliflower Grew
From the ground she didn't even know but
uh uh I got two two points to make and
that one but the first is I said no food
comes from Farms or like I suppose
theoretically you could you know go pick
in from the wild but you know he's like
what do you mean it's at the store the
food's at the store and I'm like
holy crap do you not know about the
supply chain
they don't and it's because some people
are just not that smart and they don't
they they can't think like you said one
step ahead uh I'll give you a better
example of someone who actually is smart
but doesn't know and lacks the knowledge
that's Kyle Kolinski
he's a great guy he's a good dude I'm
not trying to be mean to him but he had
that Infamous tweet where he took a
picture from a plane of farms and said I
wonder why it looks this way he's an
example of someone who does read who
does know a lot but is missing key
information and key facts so when he
sees a farm from overhead he's like how
does this happen and everyone's like bro
those are farms that's where food comes
from he's not a dumb guy he just lacked
this one detail this one bit of
information but that's going to severely
influence all of his voting patterns and
policy positions that's the issue I
think it's a combination of when when I
bring a democrat in here and I say
here's a video of Joe Biden saying
you're not getting a billion dollars
I've never seen that before because they
they're trapped in the CNN World and
they can't see out of it you then have
other people who can't think One Step
Beyond their actions so I guess my point
ultimately here is
it's it's not a disorder necessarily
it's just that
you know I'm trying to not say they're
just stupid but there's what happens is
if you get a group of politicians saying
vote for me I'll give you free stuff
they go wow I'm not going to vote for it
they're first order thinkers yes and and
you go to a conservative and say vote
for me I'll give you free stuff like
from where and they'll say we'll just
give you the money from who like we can
print it and what's that going to do to
inflation in my savings they have
questions to be asked about what the
ramifications are going to be Democrats
tend not to Republicans tend to which
then puts more inquisitive uh less
agreeable people are gonna be on the
right there's going to be this
organization there's going to be in
funding there's gonna be challenges and
the left is going to become a
collectivist mob of people who are like
good thing versus a bad thing well I'm
all for uh a good spirited debate in
fact I like that uh in fact I mean
they've banned all my videos from every
social media platform but I mean really
that's what kind of got me my big first
step in politics was going out on the
streets and talking to liberals talking
to Democrat voters and realizing how
ignorant that they actually are people
were stunned it's like hey why don't you
like Trump they couldn't even answer the
question I watched uh so I think this is
like two days ago last week or whatever
I'm sitting on my couch playing Ballers
gate three I got a steam deck you guys
those are awesome it's a handheld like
Place PC games I'm super excited for
this town so but it plays Steam games on
this handheld and it's really awesome
I'm playing and so we put on them we go
on Amazon and there's a documentary I
forgot the name of it but it's a
Democrat Woman made a documentary
several like years and years ago about
how her uncle or her dad was her dad
turned into a right-wing nut job and
it's all about how Rush Limbaugh was
evil and it had like the dude from Media
Matters in it talking about the
right-wing media ecosystem and I'm like
the Media Matters dude lies all the time
like these people are depraved but the
people who don't understand what's
happening blindly believe their cult
leaders and March in lockstep and when
in this documentary they talk to she
interviews her dad and asks him
questions like didn't you used to be a
Democrat he says I did but that's
because I didn't know anything and then
once I started looking at everything I
started to realize what was going on and
it's like interesting how that plays out
well here's a perfect example real
quickly Monica let's talk about I think
everybody here would be let's just let's
just make a specific example who here
wants us to continue to send billions of
dollars to Ukraine anybody nobody right
okay so we've sent hundreds of billions
to Ukraine when a socialist or leftist
comes up to me and says we need to have
money for health care we need to have
money for education I sit there and I
say okay let's just pause I'll hear you
out I don't like big government I'm not
a socialist at all but you know what
hold on let's maybe reach a logical
conclusion okay where are you going to
get that money are we going to stop
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
on the military industrial complex I'll
tell you what I'm not for big government
spending but if you wanted to take those
funds and invest it into America you
might have my ear I might actually be
willing to hear that argument out but
it's like you said Tim they just think
it just comes out of nowhere it's just
magic land free money for everything I
just watched an episode of It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia I don't know if it
was new or not but it was called The
Gang gets inflated I don't know if you
guys have seen it but it's uh it starts
with they're hanging out wondering why
things are getting more expensive rent
is going up and then Frank explains
inflation and it's like it's it's it's a
tremendous it's an amazing episode I
haven't watched it so it's not in a long
time but when you talk to these people
like AOC said we should deficit spend
for health care they don't understand
the concept of how money Works how
inflation Works what inflation means for
your savings for your retirement for
older people in their minds they're like
money gets food so just print more of it
and it's like okay money represents
value and it's a trade medium for the
labor you do to get the food from the
labor someone else did if we just print
money and give it to everybody and they
buy all the food there's no food and no
one making food you're going to maximize
Demand by giving everyone access to this
to the market and then remove all of the
products from the market without
creating anything because the people who
are buying the food aren't creating
anything so you see what happens here
prices begin to Skyrocket they don't get
that in their minds
just print money right and so there's
that famous quote
they attribute it to the Native American
guy where he said only when all of the
rivers are dried and you know Sky air is
polluted and the fields are Barren will
people realize that you can't eat money
and then the left all laughs about it
and I'm like it's it's actually a really
great quote but I'd say you know only
after all of the stores are closed all
of the prices are through the roof all
the savings have been crushed will
socialists realize you can't eat money
you want to print money indefinitely but
not produce anything here's here's how
it's supposed to work I provide a
service I produce something of value I
manufacture something and then I get
money for that labor in the market I
then use that money to trade with other
people so value is created and value is
exchanged yep you receive money for the
value you produce you exchange it so the
level of value in the system is at a
constant if you just dump money into
system and give it away to people then
value is being stripped from the system
yeah they can't they can't think through
that economics 101. I think there is a
lot of ignorance I think you're exactly
right about that that there are a ton of
people who just don't know but I also
think there are a lot of people on the
left who do know and they just don't
care so they reject it it's not that
they don't get it they do and they
reject it they're they're straight of
marxist they're socialists are coming
however you want to determine it but you
know the the difference between the
right and the left
it's it's so much bigger than just the
policy differences that we might have
because the left treats their ideology
as a theology yes okay it's a religion
right that's what Elon Musk just said so
well we are over here talking in Stark
terms of terms of like numbers like in
terms of the deficit or attack logic
reality
policy you know like you just laid out
Tim in terms of how a free market works
well we're over here talking about that
they are over here in a secular Rapture
100 let me uh that's why they think they
have the moral High ground there's two
ships passing in the night let me let me
let me prove that for you uh let me play
this video clown World posted this clip
that's been that's made the rounds for a
few years and I'm going to play yeah it
came back recently but I'm gonna play it
for you here uh this is your proof that
we are dealing with a Cults hope you
enjoy about racism anti Darkness or
violence
so good I will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and do everything in my power to educate
my community this is called a profession
of Faith Yep this is like the national
Creed hundred percent
look at what they're worshiping with
their hands they got their face muzzles
they're
professionals this is a cult there is no
so uh let's let's talk about a religion
versus a cult religions and this is
what's funny because they like to call
there's a lot of people who like to call
Christianity a cult and I'm like well
maybe when I was 17 I might have said
something like that but then you learn
about the prominent and well-respected
philosophers of olden days who happen to
be Christians their teachings their
writings very very brilliant things were
written by many people who were
Christian Catholic or otherwise and we
still look to these when we reference
Law blackstone's formula for instance
which lends to the fifth and sixth
amendments I mean a a plethora of the of
the Bill of Rights actually and it's
rooted in the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah in the Bible you have a
religion where people are asking deep
philosophical moral and spiritual
questions you have a cult which does
none of those things doesn't believe in
any of it blindly follows without
question these people are worshiping
nothing
nothing there's no tenets there's no
moral framework there there's no
there's nothing to live by just the
power of those who are the high priests
and Priests of the cult that's why it's
a cult and they're five minutes of hate
don't forget about their five minutes
yes thank you or well yes absolutely and
by the way you know they have their
hands in the air and as you say Tim
they're worshiping nothing but they're
in this secular Rapture and what they're
repeating is all words of love and
tolerance use your voice for good they
are the most vicious
intolerant uh uh monsters on the face of
the Earth not everybody a lot of these
people just get sucked in they don't
even know what they're doing but the
leaders leading these kinds of movements
are the most vicious and evil and we
should talk about all this stuff in
spiritual terms evil is at the root of
so much of what we say and let's let's
be real here because I can already hear
the the defense from many of these
liberal leftist types and I hate call
them liberals because they're not really
liberal saying like oh in religions
didn't have colds and blow Bloods like
dude look a lot of people were killed in
the name of God you name the religion
and there's religious conflict of War
zealots and cult-like behavior and
really awful things I'm simply saying
there's a difference between a cult and
a religion there seems to be a purpose
to a religion there are Bad actors and
there are good actors just like they are
good humans and bad humans anywhere
within Cults it is meaningless
collectivist zealotry so you look at
this crowd in this video what do you
think would happen if say like Andy no
walked through it
assault battery right and we know that's
true because it's quite literally what
they did to him imagine what would
happen if someone like billboard Chris
walked by this filming and tried to ask
them questions same story same story and
we know because it's happened to him but
the funny thing is when there was a
trump rally in the Pacific Northwest and
a guy showed up doing Nazi salutes and
screaming racial slurs what did the
Trump supporters do they told him to
leave and he wasn't welcome because they
didn't want the hate really amazing this
is a cult you have people you know it's
fascinating you have the the the the the
saying that you know a lot of people a
lot of progressives like to say the old
world is dying and the new world
struggles to be born
they're referencing their weird cult
religion trying to emerge but the
reality is the old world is the uniparty
establishment that's been around since
perhaps 1913 or slightly before then and
then implemented with a lot of these
changes we saw over the past Century and
now you have two new worlds trying to be
born the Resurgence of the
constitutional republic or the
progressive neo-marxist Revolution
The Establishment unit party took over a
long time ago and morphed this country
into something grotesque Foreign Wars
for the Empire nation-building garbage
nonsense and now you have with Bernie
Sanders and with Trump These two
factions popping up and trying to
establish their world view
I happen to like the constitutional
republic and the Constitution and the
individual liberties meritocracy uh and
things like that and I'm opposed to
Blind cellatry so it's fascinating that
in this culture War we can hang out with
Seamus Coughlin a devout Catholic uh
every day on this show for six months
out of the year for the past couple
years and uh we have we'll have
questions and conversations about faith
and religion with smiles on our faces
and then we'll go to Waffle House
afterwards and we'll laugh and make
jokes together because that's what the
constitutional republic was this great
Melting Pot of people trying to
understand each other in their world if
you disagree you are the enemy and they
physically attack you they then accuse
their enemies of being the ones who
physically attack people when they don't
well and and you know this was part of
let's say the old America or a better
America the America of the past is that
rich people and poor people they shared
the same sidewalks they shared the same
restaurants they shared the same bars
they went to the same ball games they
flew on the same Airlines and and that
was it whether you were Rich whether you
were poor whether you were middle class
everybody respected the fact that hey
we're all rich in Freedom and so we can
all share the same things and we can all
get along because we appreciate our
freedoms more than we care about how
much money the guy to my left has or how
poor the guy to my left is and and now
it's this elitism that we see where the
the financial Elite the global Elite
believe that they have the moral High
ground and it's their duty to tell us
how to live and what's what's what's
what's what's really frustrating and I'm
not a big historian but I had you know
I've had people reach out to me and and
Veterans and people and they say Owen
in in my day
we used to invade countries for what
they're doing to you we used to go into
banana republics and and we would shut
that down and we would try to restore a
constitutional republic and so what what
or or maybe inform a democracy as they
would at least used to claim and so
what's frustrating is that we went
through an entire Century of testing
this methodology right what works better
communism or free market capitalism look
at what was built in the west versus the
fall of Russia right or if you want to
maybe a better example look at North
Korea compared to South Korea well now
it's like we have to learn the lessons
of the 20th century all over again yes I
want to I want to show this uh meme real
quick to prove Owen's point
this is uh Christy Yamaguchi main said
the Taco Bell drive through at 1am will
have a 200 000 Mercedes S65 waiting
right behind a 96 Cavalier that's never
had the oil changed followed by a moped
ridden by three people all craving the
same thing to live Moss truly the last
great Melting Pot of class in this
country that's it but that that it's
this is this is literally true because
uh we got a local Taco Bell out here and
I haven't I didn't have Taco Bell in
like a decade and then me and my
girlfriend were driving oh no no the
first time was I was we were Sheamus and
we drove past at Taco Bell and Sheamus
was like he asked us if we wanted to
live moss and we were like I mean Taco
Bell's really good and so I'm in a Tesla
and we pull up behind like a like a
Honda Civic and there's like a Toyota
and it's exactly the story we just
cheesy gordita crunches man those are
good but but that's the thing about
America is that what I truly love about
this country having traveled all over
the world the idea that some working
class do with dirt in his hands can be
standing on the sidewalk when his when
the mayor of his of a city of two
million walks by and he can give him the
middle finger and say F you you're a
scumbag and they can't do anything about
it well not anymore oh now it's like
traveling though and I mean you try that
and you're likely to get arrested right
Joe Biden is a pedophile
wait you're not quoting my sentencing
document oh yeah we're not getting into
that yet look you know we we're trying
to apply logic here right and the other
side is not engaged in logic whatsoever
they're deeply immersed in ideology of
course but what Trump's ideology for the
left is power it's the pursuit of power
it's the acquisition of power and it's
the exercise of power that is what
drives them so what what we just
described with Taco Bell that's the way
America is supposed to be America has
always been an aspirational Society we
don't hate the guy in the Mercedes we
all want to be the guy in the Mercedes
right and Achieve and the left realized
that there was no currency in that so
they realized they could not gain a
foothold of power in America if we all
loved each other and we're all
aspirational and we all supported each
other
so happy people don't Revolt I say I say
this all the time happy happy people
like good families don't vote they came
right in with divide and conquer and
that's what all of this is whether it's
gender race political values doesn't
matter they have come in with giant
wedges to blow us all apart and it is in
my opinion it's a crime against you you
mentioned race and back in I think it
was probably the 50s hurt this guy
Herbert Mark Hughes you probably heard
his name yeah um Herbert Mark Hughes
pointed out that the Revolutionary
energy was no longer in the working
class because capitalism delivers the
goods your average person that just that
will go to work and you know not be late
and do their job they won't be poor if
you're in America Ben Shapiro says if
you're in America you finish High School
you don't have a kid outside of marriage
and you get a job and keep it for a
couple years you will not be in poverty
in America now this this the what
poverty means to some people might be
different but you're not going to be
destitute you're not going to be broke
you're not going to be you're not going
to be unable to pay your bills you're
not going to be unable to feed yourself
if you follow those three rules but you
CA the the communist or Marquis is
saying that the when the Revolutionary
energy was no longer in the working
class you had to go to you had to go to
race to race basically race Marxism and
that's where all of the intersectional
stuff has come from basically trying to
put different races against each other
because when Society was all focused on
everybody trying to be basically a a
classical liberal trying to better
themselves Society works together when
you have when you have the ability to
separate pieces people by classes then
you have the ability to to cause you
know fights and Chaos let's jump to this
story we have this story from Politico
Owen Shroyer Infowars host and colleague
of Alex Jones get 60 days for January 6
misdemeanor the judge contended that
Shroyer played a role in amping up the
mob at a sensitive moment during the
riot I just want to address that subhead
right away uh Owen Shroyer was not
criminally charged for incitement or
anything pertaining to what other people
did uh oh and I believe you were charged
for just being in a restricted area
so do you want to dig into this do you
want to go into the details I want that
to be really clear right away
the judge contended you amped people up
so they're sending you to prison for a
crime you did not commit
that a crime they did not charge you
with that's correct I ended up facing
one charge in this
proceeding and that was entering and
remaining on restricted grounds and
without going too into the weeds in this
for obvious reasons
find me one other person
in my situation that's facing those
charges you can't so what am I left to
assume I'm being targeted what else am I
left to assume when I'm the only one
that is having this result
and what's interesting and we can
whenever you want to Tim I mean we can
dig into this sentencing document but
when you go back and we're we're trying
to get the transcription of today's
report events to be expedited because
there was no cameras or recordings
allowed in the courtroom so there's a
lot of stuff in there that I think is
going to wow the people so we're trying
to get the transcription of those
proceedings uh published as quickly as
possible because what you find out is
that
the government is trying to have their
cake and eat it too they're trying to
argue that this is not a free speech
case that is their argument that this is
not a free speech case and yet at every
point in their presentation today
their argument was based off of
something that I said there are four
different sections in this sentencing
memo four different Headliners every
single one of them is based off of my
speech now what's also interesting about
this is they have to admit in the
document now they won't say Alex Jones's
name for whatever reason they call them
person well he's so he's person one
person one that's like that should be
his new moniker as like person one he
should just like own that person one but
they admit it they even have a quote in
here try to de-escalate
so they quote in the document that we
tried to de-escalate and then their
final argument is that I tried to amp it
up which one is it but but hold on there
good sir weren't you charged for being
on restricted grounds yes what does
amping up a crowd have to do with being
in the wrong place if a guy steals a
bottle of wine from a liquor store and
then the prosecutor says he once yelled
at a dog I'm gonna be like I young and a
dog's not illegal saying mean words to a
dog doesn't has nothing to do with him
stealing wine why is it even a part of a
sentencing document because it's clearly
about your speech who you are what you
do and
you know look I got a photo here NBC
News posted it posted this
says U.S District Court for DC and
there's a a red circle over an
individual that I'm I guess they're
saying it's you right yes uh there's a
whole bunch of other people that are
there including Alex Jones standing
right next to you
are they gonna criminally charge Alex
Jones
well I I prefer not even to answer that
question but like
you look at the charges you look at the
sentencing document
it is to uh I would say a reasonable
person concludes when they read that
document they they highlight your speech
before during and after
oh well hold on there a minute your
speech about politics it's not like you
it's one thing if your speech was yes I
did this thing haha and I'll get away
with it too no no no it was you on a
show saying the election was stolen and
things like that and they said that was
why you should go to prison
for the charge of being on restricted
grounds completely unrelated if they had
charged you for incitement perhaps that
would have made they didn't because
nothing you said was legal incitement
exactly I should say illegal incitement
and and this is a serious topic and not
to get too campy but the reason why you
joked at the top of the show about if
you're a member of the federal
government you can't tune in tonight is
because the joke is that clearly the
federal government listens to everything
I say and this document is proof
positive and there's even another level
of irony to this
I have been banned off every social
media platform just like Alex Jones we
have to create our own platform at
band.video just so our shows can exist
so and we now know that the federal
government was pursuing these censorship
issues thanks to Elon Musk the Twitter
files the Facebook files and so how
ironic is this the federal government
pushes to have Infowars Alex Jones
myself all censored off the social media
platforms and then they still tune in
every day but here's a question I mean
is is there a I gotta ask a lawyer about
this I was Joe early in the show for
those that are just watching the segment
I said if you uh I hereby revoke
authorization to timcast.com if you are
a federal agent of the government or an
agent of the federal government uh and
if you watch the uncensored show you'll
be in violation of the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act I'm kidding by all means
you are allowed to watch it but I really
wonder about that is there like a legal
way to do that because what you guys do
is you say if uh the authorization for
access to band up videos only for
non-governmental employees and if you
are an employee of the federal
government you must subscribe at the at
the one thousand dollar per day level
let's start Millions
really pay for it to watch you guys yeah
and they're gonna be like well we can't
afford that now they'll do it anyway I
mean of course it's ridiculous they'll
print the money right they'll find out
they'll find out where it comes from
well do you do you know what what's the
deal what are they gonna uh when when
when do they lock you up so there's
still some nuts and bolts to this
there's still some loose ends to this
um if if people want to get a lot of the
information myself and my lawyer had a
press conference outside of the
courthouse today after the proceedings
were finished you can go find that
exclusively at band.video and myself and
my lawyer I mean we we go into it we go
into the weeds we go into the nuts and
bolts
um and so really all the information can
be found there
is like a link or what like is it yeah
if you go to band.video I'm sure you
know I've been running around all day I
haven't gone to check myself but I'm
sure they have it in the front fold or
in the scrolling Marquee so I know it
should be easy to find or at
infowars.com
um but as far as what's next we do plan
to appeal
there's still some questions as far as
um
I mean we're assuming that we're going
to be able to appeal it'd be it'd be I
mean it'd be like almost as shocking as
the incarceration almost as shocking as
the sentence if they didn't let me
appeal but I mean at this point you know
who knows they may deny the appeal
um and I will also tell you that we
believe that this is an important enough
case to make it to the Supreme Court and
maybe that's where we prefer this case
ends up is that the Supreme Court
because we believe it is that big of a
free speech issue uh for the time being
and my lawyer let the court today know
that we plan to appeal and so at least
for the time being even though I think
the government was kind of biting their
cheek they are going to allow me to not
be incarcerated and remain under my
strict probation during the appeals
process the same probation I've been
under now again
this could all change like the wind
could change directions right and so
when that happens they'll set a date
that I have to turn myself in and and
the rest will uh we'll learn from there
there's still some nuts and bolts I
think that we have to kind of find out
for the rest of the week I'll have more
answers to that if people want to find
my show and I'll keep them updated with
my lawyer at band Out video I host the
war room
um but you know here here's the thing
Tim
there's there's two levels of of me when
I when I look at this and when I think
about this and where it impacts me
obviously the personal level is I don't
want to go to jail I don't believe I
belong in jail
I would even tell you that I believe
that this case should be done and I've
served my probation with good behavior
nonetheless that's not the result that
we got today then there's the other side
of me that's just an American citizen I
remove myself from the picture and it
breaks my heart it breaks my heart that
future Americans may have to suffer
through the same fate or worse it breaks
my heart that somebody a young
journalist coming up or a talk show is
coming up is going to have to censor
themselves chill their free speech or be
afraid that's the thing be afraid of
what they're going to say that's the
thing that people really have have
missed with this whole situation and
again we talked about first order
thinking earlier everyone that's like oh
it's fine they're they're all guilty of
first order thinking because it's not
their political party it's not something
to agree with this is going to be used
against uh first conservatives if the
government gets away with it right so
they first this is the test the small
little see what we can get away with
every time the government success fully
does something that is questionable or
illegal questionably legal or illegal
that only ensures that they're going to
do more later this is not gonna there's
never a time where the government says
oh this is this isn't a new power this
is only in this case they're going to
look at this as oh no now we can go
after people that say that that skirt
the line or whatever there's always
going to be an escalation and this is
going to turn around if conservatives
get into office again this will be used
on the left absolutely I mean and I'm
going to endorse it well it's going to
be used on the left by the left yeah
what what I just just to reference you
know like every Communist Revolution
the first group to be purged is the
revolutionaries yeah because the most
people that die from communism are
communists thankfully right when when uh
when we're talking about evil
authoritarians who go around murdering
people we need that we want that to not
be the case and in these revolutions I
mean look at Robespierre live by the
sword as it goes when a revolution
happens you now have factions vying for
political power to have their Vision
come true and and the the meme is
there's like a bunch of people standing
around all with the same thought bubble
saying I can't wait for for the collapse
to happen so that my ideology will take
over well what happens when the system
collapses is all these different groups
now say my way no my way no my way and
then someone gets slightly more
political power and says we've got to
take out anybody who fomented Revolution
because they're our only threat the
regular people who sit by and don't do
anything they're no threat to the
machine so if these anti-fall leftists
and crack Bots get their way they're
going to be the first to be locked up in
in you know in federal prisons and kept
away from sunlight and Communications
because they're the real risk to the new
to the new machine well and and you know
Monica you were getting into this
earlier and it goes back to the one
train of thought uh I I don't forgot the
phrase that you used him the one line of
thinking here but you know okay look at
some policies of the left what do they
want well they they want to let's just
use the Second Amendment take they want
to disarm Americans okay so I always ask
how many people have to die for you to
disarm every American how many people
are gonna have to die in that process
and are you going to be allowed to use
guns are you going to be allowed to use
guns to disarm the fellow Americans and
so why does the left seek power because
their policies inherently need power it
is it is a necessity to have
totalitarian control in order to achieve
the Communist Doctrine and so for all of
these people who think they can go along
to get along you know I'm on their
quote-unquote right side right now
they're feeding the alligator hoping
that the alligator eats them last right
and and so we we've seen this throughout
history history repeats itself because
human nature is what it is right but Tim
to your point about how the different
factions then end up cannibalizing each
other right now in the world you've got
three major forces and they're all on
the same side now to knock off the
United States of America which is the
biggest obstacle to their globalist
plans you've got the globalist Marxist
Revolution you've got the CCP which is a
form of it but unto itself and you've
got the islamists and so all three
factions want to see the end of Western
Civilization certainly the end of
America so they're all working together
now to accomplish that but once they
knock over America assuming that they're
able to accomplish it then they're going
to go to war with each other and that's
going to be a global conflagration that
you don't want to be a part of I want to
pull up this story from the
post-millennial oh boy this is a good
one New Mexico attorney general says he
won't defend the governor in lawsuits
over ban on carrying guns my duty to
uphold and defend the constitution
rights constitutional rights of every
citizen takes precedence so let me just
let me break this down for you guys what
this means right many of you probably
know but the AG is the state's top
lawyer when they're sued it's the
attorney general who is going to be
dealing with drafting a lawsuit or a
rebuttal or whatever and filing lawsuits
on behalf of the state and uh this means
the governor will be on her own and I I
don't I don't know how she's gonna pull
this off there are already lawsuits
being filed for the decree to ban guns
the AGS like I'm not defending you
you're on your own so how is her office
going to do to respond to this it's
going to be default judgment instantly
across the board that's amazing I mean
so that she might actually lose her
office I mean the taxpayer could lose a
lot of money from this yeah well and and
I'm I you know I'm hoping and I mean I
could talk about it personally but I'll
just make a general statement I'd like
to see any attorney general I wouldn't
expect that from Merrick Garland anytime
soon but I'd like to see a widespread
approach from any sort of attorneys
generals that says we are not going to
prosecute speech yeah you bring us you
bring a free speech case to us we are
not going to prosecute it we are going
to toss it out much like what you're
seeing with this New Mexico case
I think I don't know I've got a theory
about this New Mexico case I think it
was a trial balloon yep I think you know
they they just they knew what they were
doing they did it in New Mexico for a
reason they didn't do it in the
northeast or anything like that and they
ran this up the flagpole to see what the
response would be they enlisted this
Governor to do it
they got blow back they must have seen
some internal polls in the first 24
hours that were off the wall bad and
that's why they they sent out David Hogg
and uh who was the other big uh Pro guy
oh yeah all of their tweets were the
exact same language there is no State
exemption to the cut to a constitutional
success right but I'd like to introduce
them to their opinions during covid
because exactly yeah quite the opposite
this is what they do though they
manufacture a crisis they make up a
crisis out of thin air and then they go
down this path and the next thing you
know you have no rights yeah right so
this I think was a trial balloon it was
trying to pave the path to kind of
normalize this kind of thing so while
we're celebrating that it didn't work
now they're they're they're taking
another step to normalizing taking away
your guns and what's even more
frustrating again it gets back to the
same issue there is no data that
supports this approach there is no data
that supports this policy and in fact
well and in fact the exact opposite
whether it's Kennesaw Georgia where it's
the most heavily armed County and
there's the least amount of gun crime or
whether it's what happened in Brazil
recently or they always point to
Australia and they say oh we got rid of
the guns and the guns crime went down
actually when they made the new laws in
Australia more gun purchases happened
there I'm sorry Owen you were wrong uh
you're just wrong there's tons of data
showing that what they're doing Works in
a Communist Revolution
their view on why you shouldn't have
guns is not based on your view of why
you should have guns when we say things
like hey look I live in a semi-rural
area mostly rural area and the police
aren't going to be here if we if we've
got a serious issue so we need to defend
ourselves you know where they do want to
defund the police too so that's not out
of left field argument that's very
relevant the the argument that we have
is if you have a gun you are safer the
argument they have is I will lie to you
because in order to steal political
power I have to take away your ability
to fight back or defend yourself and
then you and and also the creation of
anarcho tyranny you look at what's
happening in San Francisco you see that
viral video of the young woman being
like I parked at a time would you like
parked at a Taco Bell or something and
then went inside for five minutes which
one oh I know there's dozens of these
now tourists that's embarrassing and
remember when CNN twice that happened to
CNN and we laugh about it like ah you're
about you so
but it's the intent no it's actually
it's the Anarchy tyranny they want there
was a story
um out of St Louis where a young
volleyball player high school volleyball
star was set to go on scholarship play
volleyball in high school uh College
rather she's at a high school volleyball
tournament in St Louis she leaves the
tournament she's walking outside she
gets run over and paralyzed and can no
longer play volleyball the individual
that ran her over was on release already
a multiple time offender on release Let
Go by a George Soros liberal attorney
and what do you know caused harm again
but but you know I I would go because
here's here's where I think the legal
Theory needs to go and this would
probably nip this ride in the bud
let's let's propose a hypothetical here
let's say that the New Mexico governor
somehow is able to disarm the citizenry
okay and let's say let's say let's say
Monica you live in New Mexico and you're
like oh my gosh the governor's right I'm
turning over my firearms okay you've now
turned over your Firearms you're a great
person the policy is working well what
happens and I'm sorry I'm not trying to
traumatize you what happens when a
criminal with a gun breaks into your
house rapes you and murders you is the
governor now complicit in that crime
how is she not and libel how is she not
you you were disarmed some legal
responsibility then for disarming me
that's what I'm saying if I come up and
I disarm you and then and then seconds
later
somebody comes up and commits a crime to
you well I helped cause that crime to be
committed I made you a victim took a
defense away yeah
but is anybody thinking about that legal
Theory because to me that's that's the
the one thing again and this goes back
whether it's the illegal immigration the
Democrats hating the taste of their own
medicine that's the one thing that will
always stand down a communist when they
realize they're going to be held
responsible when bad things happen when
they realize they're going to be held
responsible that will stop them they
just think they're above it all yeah
they do well they're also protected from
the consequences of their own policies
and decisions right because they live in
the gated communities they've got that
armed security and the rest look
throughout history anytime the
Communists have come to power one of the
very first things they do is empty all
the prisons yeah so all the violent
criminals pour out onto the streets why
because Communists need the violent may
have they need the violent chaos to
destabilize Society to slam into place
what they want yeah they're the ones
with the with the control and all the
actual system yeah it's like
Ghostbusters when uh exactly it is
same Peck or whatever I don't really
turns off the containment field I'm
really sorry
chaos yeah yeah you know we can't have
that yeah I mean I think that joke for
me like 800 times about how they're
releasing everybody from prisons that's
true yeah well I mean it it doesn't have
to be releasing they could just not put
people in prison with that or criminals
but look I I gotta say I gotta say you
know a few people have responded when I
keep saying that we're winning and
they're saying no we've only just
stopped losing and I'm like you've got
to have morale you know like if if all
of if you're in a battle you know if
it's an actual War and the enemy
controls 80 of the battlefield and
you're making small gains you don't go
we're really losing this one guys but I
guess we'll keep going you say we're
taking it we're winning storm head and
you know what I see sure the left
controls the institutions look what
they're trying to do with banning guns
they're losing these moves aren't
working it doesn't mean they're not
trying and you give up it means we're
watching them break ranks when they
break ranks you don't run away you don't
say oh gee will like gee well we're
losing here you say charge so when I see
the tremendous economic success of all
of these parallel economic Brands when I
see I mean they tried to destroy my
pillow my pillow's still around you
can't get rid of those pillows don't you
say it's a lumpy pillow
that's a lumpy pillow I saw that video I
was just gonna reference that when uh
it's it's
um Mike Lindell in a deposition I think
it was right yeah and then they they he
mentioned the guy says something about
your lumpy pillows he's like how dare
you it is not a lumpy pillow it was
really good I mean my pillows are
awesome by the way but anyway you look
at that you look at
um even right now uh you've got cousin
T's pancake mix there you go you got
Jeremy's razors Jeremy's chocolate
conservative dad's Ultra ripe beer and
now their limited editions conservatives
dad's Revenge yeah we're having fun
we're having fun and laughing as we
build Alternatives and get rich doing it
and we keep the the money within our
system look at rumble's success their
new UI let me tell you this the success
of Rumble I was on Instagram looking at
skateboard videos and I saw a video I
think it was Paul Rodriguez one of the
most famous skateboarders in the world
at his private park and Rumble Sports
was on their wall and I'm like when
regular old skateboarders are going to
rumble to watch skateboarding YouTube's
in trouble and we're winning the culture
War because Rumble the politics of
Rumble are all the refugees of YouTube
who got censored in band which are more
and more more and more but if kids
younger teenagers are going to go to
rumble and they're watching
skateboarding what's on their
recommendation list for podcasts it's
going to be Real News Real information
it's going to be independent media and
the Machine can't control that anymore
well and I think too when you talk about
the emergence of Rumble as I mean I
would say it's the number one competitor
to YouTube on on a large scale hands
down they're really still kind of in the
primordial ooze of of what they could
potentially be and as I know as a
Creator yourself you know that there's a
lot of bells and whistles that they're
going to be needing to Tinker with and
fix but they're still kind of they're
still kind of crawling out of that that
media ooze to to become a much better
platform but you know when you get to
them when you get to the issue that you
bring up where people say oh we're not
winning or oh this is bad morale down I
think there's I think there's I mean I
could boil it down to two fundamental
questions that I would respond to
somebody like that and I would just say
and and you know maybe people will
answer how they want and I would just
say Do you believe America is worth
fighting for yeah do you believe freedom
is worth fighting for I I've been saying
to people uh when they say like you know
how do I get started I want to make
videos or I'll do a podcast I'm like
just do it on Rumble because YouTube's
not safe YouTube's got too many barriers
it's too hard to to exist on and it's
not worth it especially I'll tell you
this right now
the this is actually really really funny
the amount of money we make on YouTube
has gone down you know why because so
many of our viewers have moved to rumble
we now average for timcast IRL I think
around 50 000 views on Rumble per clip
whereas we used to get hundreds of
thousands we now get like a hundred or
so thousand maybe like 50 to 100K on
YouTube now 50 can Rumble Rumble is
rolling up more and more monetization I
really need them to do that right like
so so but this is because we want Rumble
to be the definitive viable alternative
for running your business the
competition between YouTube and Rumble
is healthy yeah YouTube got to a point
where they're like we can censor whoever
you want because you can't go anywhere
else Rumble emerges they've got a bigger
and bigger audience the viewership is
becoming massive you like Dan bongino
before he got banned from YouTube had
more viewers on Rumble so when we see
that once Rumble gets the point where
they're running ads comparable to
YouTube YouTube is done because
someone's going to say I've got two
choices YouTube will censor me if I fart
too loud Rumble will let me be me why
would you go to YouTube if they're
paying comparably well and I would say I
would say too as somebody that I mean
I'm like a media addict I consume media
like a fiend I mean I'm I'm constantly
consuming media and the one advantage
that YouTube still has and maybe this
will change with time is they have the
archives they've been around for a long
time they've got the archives they've
got a lot of establishment things
they're always going to go up there but
now if I'm thinking hey I want to go
find a news story or I want to go watch
a news live stream or I'm looking for
latest breaking news now I'm always
going to rumble Rumble is always now my
first source for that information I
don't even think about going to well to
be honest I go to x well
yeah yeah and musk is really trying I
mean he's trying to make X Twitter can I
campaign my account back now I mean look
uh I'm really excited for everything
Elon has done with x uh the Rebrand is I
I don't really care that much I find it
funny calling from Twitter to X people
still call Twitter but it's I'm making
money I'm just I post a lot of goofy
tweets you know and I I'm making money
off of the the interactions I have now I
do think they have some refining to do
because the monetization strategy they
have resulted in everyone just asking
questions all day yeah which is like I
roll my eyes at but we're just putting
click bait out there yeah and so we want
to avoid that but it really it really is
going to be up to you to just not follow
bad accounts if they're doing that it's
that simple but the fact that it's
becoming a viable platform for
generating revenue and running a
business awesome the more competition in
the space the better the more viable
Alternatives but of course Owen needs to
have his Twitter account so so let me
explain why this is an important thing
um
it's beyond just me getting my original
Twitter account back your XX I'm sorry
I'm sorry my original well actually
technically I've technically it was
never on X and and considering it's a
new platform I think you should unban
everybody and say it's a new platform I
agree I agree including one person one
and uh and really quite frankly all the
other Infowars accounts that got the
mass Banning but here's why here's
here's why it's beyond just the
censorship issue when we're dealing with
my case so my original account at all I
do is Owen had a couple hundred thousand
followers when they banned me I don't I
don't want to have to build up another
account I don't want to go through that
again I want my account back I want my
history I want my archives I want all
that I want the Nostalgia I want the
memories but here's what's crazy about
it there are multiple oh insurers
operating on X right now verified none
of them are me not a single one of the
oh insurers with a verified blue check
mark is me and people that don't know
any better and I know Tim that this this
happened with your crew too you put
something out oh and show your response
and people think oh that's the real low
introyer they reach out in a DM they
reach out in a reply something lewd
crude and appropriate gets said and
they're like geez this Owen Troyer is a
jerk I don't want to deal with him it's
not me so now not only am I being
censored I'm a victim of digital
identity theft yeah that's what's
happening now so it's not just I own I
want to be back on X I want to be famous
and popular again no I'm I am being I am
having my digital identity stolen on X
so if anybody from X is listening to
this please restore my original account
at all I do is Owen Jo and Shroyer I'm
sick of having my digital identity
stolen from me and if for if for no
other reason just so I can be on there
and address these things and hey I don't
know when I'm trending on Twitter like I
was for the last 24 hours maybe I can
get on there and speak for myself
instead of having these fake account
speaking for me illegitimately
yeah I think uh I don't see any I
understand elon's discussions about Alex
I'm sorry person one person one and
person one's response to a person one
actually said it's he understands what
Elon is doing and it makes sense and
this is the game you got to play to try
and help restore for a speech I can
respect that uh I don't see why you're
still banned
it's either it's either for my
affiliation to person one or I'm just
assuming that there's still holdovers
there's still holdovers that are just
gritting their teeth just just gritting
their teeth We're Not Gonna I just I
just love that Alex's new nickname is
person one I think you should I think
you should embrace person one I think
you should embrace it's also like he's
the number one dude you know what I mean
but tell me tell me this how how do
multiple Owen Troyer accounts get
verified how do they verified and I
can't even have my account back it's
just have you tried making a new account
uh so there has been account made for me
just for live streaming it's not my
personal Twitter account because quite
frankly I'm I'm still wanting to have
this crusade to get my original account
back based on principle and as you know
when you build something and you spend
time on that you don't want to have to
rebuild from the ground up you'd rather
get back where you left off so I mean I
guess you could say I'm starting the
Crusade now in fact if you're listening
get on X and demand tweet Elon or tweet
X and say hey please restore at all I do
is Owen he was trending on Twitter today
but all these false and
misrepresentations of him are still on
there I've appealed my suspension three
times since Elon took over it's been
rejected so how is it that they reject
my appeal and then accept fako and
Troyer accounts and verify them it's
just mind-boggling to me
yeah well that's how you you fight for
change you go on a show and say Elon
unban me please Elon please I just want
to be on I think uh I mean we didn't
even get into the Elon news they're
accusing of being a uh being a traitor
because of uh
because that story that came out where
he did not activate starlink this is
crazy right now we don't have a full
segment for you but starlink is down
across the board apparently
uh right on the same time that Elon Musk
is a traitor is trending and we've got
this report maybe we have to get into
this this is this is big well this is
big Tim because we're talking about
world war three Yahoo news the new voice
of Ukraine is the publication they're
rebroadcasting U.S to hold closed-door
meeting over whether billionaire is
conducting own foreign policy question
mark is Elon Musk a traitor now think
about what's insinuated in that headline
so Elon Musk isn't allowed to have a
dissenting opinion
Elon Musk isn't allowed to have his own
policy with his own company's property
yeah like he is the owner of SpaceX he
owns all those what color has your house
painted uh my house yeah uh it's wood
well that's illegal you you know crap
but wait wait no you have to have a blue
house now you traitor this is just like
Iron Man 2. remember in the beginning
when Tony Stark is at the Congressional
hearing and they're like we want the
Iron Man turned over to the government
and he's like you can't have it
I didn't I didn't make that
another aspect to this too which is
they're laying the groundwork to go
after him on the Logan act right that he
is a private citizen carrying out
American foreign policy in an
unauthorized way that's what they tried
to do to General Flynn right it's all
bogus again but it sounds also Senator
Elizabeth Warren today or yesterday came
forward and demanded that the Pentagon
uh conduct their own investigation into
Elon they're going to try to nationalize
Starling I mean they're going after
they're going after Tesla they're going
after him in every possible way and it
Harkens back to Senator Chuck Schumer
talking about Trump saying well if you
go after the Deep State they have six
ways to Sunday to come out after you
again well Elon now who's you know
certainly an elite richest man in the
world they're targeting him so which
what they're doing is and it's the same
thing with you Owen as it is with Elon
and the j6 defendants these are all men
messaging events their messaging events
it's don't even think about it don't
even think about standing up for the
Bill of Rights Free Speech uh Second
Amendment don't even think about
standing up for your country or we will
destroy you
yeah but it doesn't matter if you're the
richest man in the world or you're Owen
or you or me musk needs to make sure
that he has a a
one-button kill switch that just gets
all of the satellites to fall out of
orbit should they try to nationalize and
just burn up in in on re-entry
take the uh the option away from them
but they they I really do think they're
going to try and
try to nationalize SpaceX they're going
to say that his ability to access the
internet and and
put the internet in places that they
don't want it and his ability to put
significant uh sizable Rockets into
space and stuff they're going to say
that that's National Security and
they're going to try now and and let's
also think about what this is going to
do to Elon musk's political beliefs and
actions I mean I can't it's only going
to make it more like on our side that's
what I'm saying I can't believe that
he's going to sit here and say oh the
Biden Administration is right I should
have let them use my technology to kill
Russians to start Newton they're
radicalizing Elon Musk to be a
deplorable absolutely and he's like hey
I just want to be a normal dude and have
common sense but that's the thing ever
like Mo your average person generally if
they don't get fed the news from CNN
then and or at least kind of if they're
not very interested in the news or
whatever and they're told the topics
that you you hear people talking about
stuff they tend to come down on what you
would consider a normal person's
perspective not a a Democrats
perspective because
ever since and I I'm not going to get
too deep into this but ever since
2012 uh the ndaa when they they uh did
these the Smith munt modernization Act
which made it legal for the federal
government to propagandize the American
people that was Obama that was Obama it
was 2012 they signed it I think or maybe
it was 2011 they signed and there's the
2013 but either way um that's when it
happened and after that everybody that I
talked to you talk to people all the
time they say oh you know in like 2013
two or so things started getting crazy
they blame it on the uh the my end of
the Mayan calendar and there's all these
things but what happened was it became
legal for the government to propagandize
the American people at the same time
there was Market saturation of your cell
phones smartphones so everyone had
social media directly in there in their
pocket and it was constantly feeding
them a drip of likes which is literally
the most powerful mind control thing
ever created so the federal government
got the access to it and they knew that
it was coming because they they saw
social media when it first started in
2004 whenever Friendster or whatever
um but they saw it and there are smart
people that said that's going to be a
big deal the like button is going to be
a big deal and as soon as it was in your
pocket and the government had their
fingers in producing propaganda all of
the social media companies came running
because the government prints the money
because that it's all access so all the
regular media they want to be buddies
with Obama and be buddies with people in
power so they go ahead and they
capitulate and they come running it's
not that there's an adversarial or there
has been an adversarial uh relationship
between the federal government and and
the media they've been one in the same
and then you start and then you throw in
the fact that there's an entire uh
security apparatus that was built up
after after 2001 and you put those three
things together the American people have
no chance well they have no chance it's
just like when the government was
testing the flicker rates of the TV to
make it as addictive as possible before
they released it but you know I I
had an amazing connection listening to
you say that and and Tim this is going
to take a trip down memory lane because
what happened in 2013 it was the Mike
Brown riots and and you remember that
was when 14 that was 14. that was when
live streaming really kind of first took
off and really that was a big movement
on Twitter and what was it it was it was
hands up don't shoot well if you ask if
you were to ask me uh the Arab Spring
was the first time we started seeing the
emergence of independent live streaming
I think the guy's name was uh was it
Muhammad nabous I believe was the guy in
in Libya and it was fairly rudimentary
and then with Occupy Wall Street we saw
people with webcams on their laptops and
then the Ustream app came out I don't
know of anyone else before me that
started using it but I started using the
Ustream app to live broadcast from my
phone on the ground with a Mobile
Battery yeah that occupied all right
2011. and then and then you were doing
the same thing at the Mike Brown riots
and and because I was there doing the
same thing too but the reason I'm making
this connection is because hands up
don't shoot might have been the first
institutionalization of that act hands
up don't shoot never happened it was the
number one trend on Twitter and other
social media marketplaces for months it
never happened it caused riots they
still chant hands up don't up to this
day even though the Obama doj admitted
it never happened could that have been
the first test case of the smithmont ACT
uh I mean I don't know I I don't know
for sure but the the the fact that you
had people on CNN you know repeating the
narrative it definitely uh it may be
when NBC News was taken over by the
intelligence agencies I think if if
there was going to be any news outlet
that I thought was under the under the
boot you know people make fun of CNN and
I'm like CNN's just garbage NBC News is
like
the evil just you know the and I'm
talking about their their digital uh
Team they've got a team of writers who I
won't say their names because they don't
want to give them the attention but
they're they're abject evil yep they
there there's no the things they've
published are such obvious Fabrications
that I don't see a reality in which
they're unaware that they're lying
cheating and stealing for political
power and so a lot of people speculate
that they're probably
you know uh what happens is
someone from an intelligence agency will
come to them and say we need this story
to run for this purpose and they'll go
you got a boss thanks for the scoop
and then they just they run what the
machine wants them to run and they get
their paycheck oh yeah and they have no
problem with it none oh no they're
willing participants there's so many
reporters that are you know active
willing organs for the security State
and just propagandize the American
people this gets back to where we were
at earlier and again it's such a
mind-boggling thing like really Obama is
a scandal-free president like you don't
you don't actually believe that the free
president that shot missiles at American
citizens without due process
free fast and furious but it's like it's
the same thing it's like oh Biden he's
so fit look he's more fit than Trump
he's totally it's just like you don't
actually believe that Joe Biden fell up
the stairs
yeah fell off why do you guys think he
ran out of that metal ceremony I think
he crapped his pants yeah that's like
yeah oh yes right and and the media came
out and said it's
it wasn't that big deal that he left the
way he did and it's like it it was kind
of abrupt I mean call whatever you want
you can argue it wasn't informal but
it's it's abrupt for him not to hang out
and shake hands and and smile and meet
people afterwards yeah he he probably
had a a bowel movement and I think the
fair and I think the fair way to analyze
this and it's not about obsessing over
what about us and I think what about ism
is fair it shows you whether you have
Justice it shows you whether you have
fairness let's just let's just ask the
question if Donald Trump walked out of a
medal of honor ceremony can you imagine
the headlines they'd accuse him of
everything it's not it's it's not
hypocrisy it's it's uh By Design
hierarchy yeah yeah that's right
well we got to go to super chats we we
went a little longer this uh this this
story was was really important but we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this YouTube channel
but more importantly take the URL share
it wherever you can word of mouth is the
most powerful tool in helping the work
that we do because advertising is is a
challenge and podcasts grow by word
mouth head over to timcast.com click
join us become a member the uncensored
show we'll be up in about 20 minutes
you're not going to want to miss it
we're gonna we're gonna have a whole lot
of fun with this one Let's uh read some
super chats
all right RJ mcdougelheim says getting
in first so I can ask this you mentioned
the skatepark idea yesterday are you
looking for help I ran a skatepark for a
while and would love to be part of it
let me know how I can well
the first thing I'll say is I always
read the first Super Chat so then we go
through and try and read a different
grouping I don't want to just read all
the biggest ones or just read small ones
we try to mix it up but I tend to read
the first one not always but typically
uh so for the skatepark what we did was
there's a property in Martinsburg which
for the past 10 years locals have built
uh their own skate obstacles on this
property now the person who owned it
previously they were not really involved
locally or anything like that
and at one point I tried to sell the
property so we bought it uh it's it's
it's a very very large property with
tons of concrete foundation already on
it which means that those that are
skateboarding there now don't have to
worry about what the owner is going to
do because we're totally into the
skateboarding in fact we want to uh
we're actually talking with a big
company about in a separate area setting
up some some ramps one cool thing we can
do is uh we can get some skate light pre
a prefab they call Pre prefabricated
um ramps and Ledges that can be placed
in a different section you know what I
don't want to do is for the people that
built their own you know little spot is
affected in any way because it's got you
know their own you know Touch of Love in
it so I told the dudes there I was like
you guys do whatever you like do your
thing there as you've been doing it
we'll go over here but we've got a ton
of land now to build a very big
legitimate professional Park and we just
got we're now navigating the the legal
uh structure of how we do this but you
know the idea would be to build a big
Recreation Area and park in Martinsburg
West Virginia
the plan of course is that we want to
create an anti-time Square perhaps we
call it a Public Square in Martinsburg
where not only do we have a coffee shop
we have a cousin T's Diner a Papa Jack's
Pizza Shack we maybe we get a my pillow
brick and mortar store a patriot mobile
cell phone shop I mean that would be the
dream so for the time being our plan is
just to have like a public open concrete
thing uh this could be between two and
three years out who knows based on
permitting legalities and things like
that but we'll figure it out that's
currently working on so it's super cool
let's grab some more we got fatty tanks
as Dave Smith had a great interview with
Vivek today he asked if he's too good to
be true and if he's afraid since he's
going after three letter agencies
oh yeah I'll check that on the way home
yeah
fatty also says I heard Elon blocked
access to Star Lincoln Crimea the real
story was that he never turned it on and
they got mad because they wanted to use
it as a weapon for Logistics as they
struck Russia and now they're calling
Elon a traitor very creepy
all right what do we got here
flying raptor Jesus as a brewery local
to me vintage Brewing Co in South
Prairie Wisconsin is having a drag show
brunch in October and as far as I can
tell it's open to minors can you shed
some light on them to make it 18 plus
well I think you just did I don't know
enough about it but I uh I would
recommend that uh you dig into it make
sure that I mean look if if they're
having a drag show for a bunch of adults
I got no beef like in fact more power to
you man have fun I hope you have a good
time if they are allowing kids then I
think you should look into that and and
bring up the issue we're going to need
everybody to be paying attention to this
kind of stuff all right let's go qatarth
Swift says talk about how the government
used the election Integrity partnership
to silence and prosecute people like
Owen and others I summon Ian
uh I I don't know enough about it I know
that basically uh you still you have
today ax has announced their you know
safety measures for election security or
something everybody rolls their eyes
look elon's done a lot of good stuff but
come on
yeah seriously the bonus hole says so
how about a culture War episode with
Hinkle Phil and James Lindsay could be
fun Shameless plug X at the bonus holes
our debut EP is almost done very
interesting if Lindsay is here like and
the topic is communism I don't even need
to show up I'm just gonna sit down and
listen the guys the guy is so deep in
this stuff and he knows way more than me
most of the stuff that I know is because
I've listened to stuff that he's talked
about or or read stuff that he said that
I should read or people should read or
whatever so radioactive rat says Tim
can't wait for the remix of all the
noises you made to censor the earlier
segment but bet it will be hilarious are
you guys heard about the Democrat who
had the adult
subscription service available on the
internet yeah and so I'm reading quotes
of what she was saying and I can't read
them on a podcast that uh you know we
have parents who are who will be driving
in their car and their kids are with
them picking up from school and they're
listening to the show and it's meant to
be a more like you know I talk news in
my opinion
but in a way where the idea can be can
get across to the parent without them
having to explain certain words and
phrases to their kids and it started
because a few years ago I was referring
to a group of people who all stand in a
big circle and they are really mean to
each other in fact they're jerks and uh
the the phrase of which I referred to
uh I got emails from people being like
hahaha I just had to explain to my kid
what you were saying in in a way that
wasn't too explicit please would you
consider you know toning it down for for
the families that may be listening and I
was like good point so now we say it's a
circle of jerks who are all really mean
but they're patting each other on the
back
but multi-purpose multi-function you
know that's right but uh but anyway in
this segment I was like the the the
Democrat says I uh I need more tokens so
that I can with my um
because I'm like I can't read what she
said dude it's messed up uh it's crazy
and now she's claiming that it was like
a leak of her private videos or whatever
it's like dude you posted them online
for people to buy and the New York Times
had a big story today calling it an
invasion of her privacy when she was
publicly posting and I'm like personal
not pornography I'm like lady I got no
beef if you're a hooker like do your
thing I I I'm not a fan of that kind of
stuff but you have to own it you can't
do it and they're like no uh like now
you look weird and weak like you gotta
own it be like that was me vote for me
is that the next move for Obama because
didn't he did it no but didn't he follow
some weird like uh you know man
accounts and stuff on on Twitter no is
that true that's what that well and now
you got the Larry Sinclair I want to
believe I mean come on Joan River said
it first yeah but we'll we'll get into
the nitty-gritty with the uncensored
show coming up in 15 minutes which will
be a lot more fun I've I've got I've
already got an opening statement for the
uncensored show for for Owen over here
uh all right here we go John Neeson said
MSNBC last night said the Republicans
were cheapening impeachment without
recognizing that Biden is on video
admitting to the very thing they
impeached Trump for threatening wild
cognitive dissonance yeah yes Joe Biden
engaging in a quid pro quo and the
response is yeah but it was American
foreign policy who sets the foreign
policy it was Obama and why does his
that foreign policy he's the president
Donald Trump was the president he sets
foreign policy he can ask Ukraine for
whatever he wants but even that's part
of the cognitive dissonance Trump was
never the President right oh yeah but
you know what speaking of Obama he has
skated throughout all of this Joe Biden
was conducting all of this alleged
bribery and everything else right under
the nose of Barack Obama he had a boss
the president so the United States and
Obama has been very quiet he is skated
through this I think it's long past time
we focus in on him what did Obama know
and when did he know it and by the way
did he benefit from any of this foreign
money and largesse that came into the
Biden family
we got um Jillian Quinones who says Owen
Shroyer did nothing wrong Owen Shroyer
did nothing wrong Owen schroyer did
nothing wrong Owen schroyer did nothing
wrong banned.video enlightening thank
you for that couldn't have said it
better myself that's right
Beau says where is the holy potato man
you've gotta you gotta send a tweet to
uh Sheamus Coughlin on Twitter and tell
him to come back I don't know where he
just disappeared he left he stole spoons
potatoes I thought they were talking
about stelter when they said potato man
that's the first oh no uh Sheamus is is
Irish and um
so the story is that I was watching
Leprechaun 2 I think it was and I'm
sitting in the in the in the it's called
the great room downstairs because like a
kitchen in it and I was watching it and
Sheamus walked in and there's a scene
where this dude is turning into a
leprechaun because he got bit and so
he's eating a bunch of crazy potatoes
it's actually in the movie and then
Sheamus like hey buddy what you watching
and he turns look at the TV he's like
what racist garbage is this like shocked
because he's Irish you know you even had
a little Irish accent with that too oh
yeah yeah yeah so Sheamus you know he's
he's American but because he's Irish you
know it became the meme that he's you
know represented by potatoes now even
though I think potatoes are not pandemic
to uh potato nationalist potato National
let's grab some more Sergeant Mister
says Iraq and Afghanistan Survivor here
keep Owen free and get us the hell out
of Ukraine yep
you know it's funny when I when I like
the arguments for why we're in Ukraine
they just the logic is missing sorry it
just is there's the logic of yes but we
promised we'd be there and we have to
maintain our treaties and I'm like Ron
Paul said one generation can't promise
the children of another so I understand
the book but if the US doesn't uphold
its treaties then what will other
countries think and I'm like too bad
well you know it's not logical it wasn't
a treaty anyways it was just it was it
was an actual treaty that would that
Congress had anything I I think it it
even goes beyond logic I mean the
situation is complex right I mean the
situation with NATO and Ukraine and the
history between Russia and Ukraine and
Belarus and everything these are complex
historical issues that you have to have
a deep understanding of you can't just
jump in and assume that oh I know
everything we should have the war
because of this no there are a lot of
complexities that go in to that
situation our foreign policy there
NATO's policy there and to think that
you can just jump in and say yeah we
need to stop Russia it ain't that simple
Jack it's an interest love fight that is
not our fight
current thing you know yep 2023 yep
well we got here the soft advice has six
months on YouTube membership woot longer
on timcast the soft wife and the fuzzy
me husband love you guys where can we
donate to help Owen defend owen.com
defend owen.com and um you know just so
people get a better understanding of
what's Happening here because of what
Alex and Infowars has gone through in
the lawsuits against him
we can't even fund lawsuits anymore we
can't even fund legal fees we can barely
even fund anything outside of what we're
capped at so now we're forced to and
believe me I don't like this I'm not the
type of person that wants to go out
asking for help but we've reached a
point in time now where if our audience
doesn't support us like this I can't go
on the road I can't have security
uh we can't travel when there's breaking
news and we can't even fund our own
lawyers anymore so I'm eternally
grateful for the Infowars audience
honestly I would uh I don't know where
I'd be without them your continued
support at defend owen.com I I can't
even I I can't even find the words to
express my gratitude except that
I'll never stop fighting for truth and
I'll never stop fighting for Freedom
period
nice man right on
think on this says Tim we are not
winning anything the average Dem voter
does not have the money to sway the
economy but every American's vote counts
equally LOL sorry could not keep that in
uh Trump lost 2020 by 42 000 votes even
if you're of the opinion that there was
widespread cheating that means even with
all of that Trump lost by only 42 000
votes in three states which I I say
I don't even think any 2020 is it
doesn't matter at this point right now
what matters right now is registering
people to vote knocking on doors getting
as many many people as possible to vote
and spreading the word as much as
possible speaking up as much as possible
being successful making money supporting
businesses you like make it impossible
for them to do whatever that whatever
they do to win and just get involved
right if you're worried about the
results then get find a way to get
involved and protect you know the
results or make sure the Integrity is
there and you know this is an issue
that's not really sexy it's not really
Punchy but it is actually going on I
mean we've had Carrie lake has had
victories in Arizona there's been a lot
of situations in Michigan as well where
they're they're finding new ways to make
sure that we don't have illegal votes so
I do tend to agree with you Tim that the
real issue is 2024 and not to relitigate
um but now it's like
they want to criminalize talking about
2020 so well so that you don't raise
questions in 2020. exactly so now you're
kind of like well gee yeah because the
federal government put their finger on
the election it's totally not worth hat
or it's not a not a legitimate election
Joe Biden is completely and totally
illegitimate
nice are the feds tuned into this right
now yeah you're going to be getting an
end I don't care that's true the the
fact that 50 people that were involved
in the uh the security State former CIA
uh lied yeah they they signed a paper
and they lied that's the federal
government putting their finger on the
election the federal government putting
their finger on the election means the
election is invalid because the federal
government is not supposed to have an
opinion on the on the election so it's
illegitimate and Joe Biden is an
illegitimate president and I don't care
how many people it pisses off the
government also putting their finger on
the on the balance scales with big tech
oh yeah 100
that is such a that is such a great
Point Phil because forget about counting
the votes okay let's just put out
counting the votes for a second whatever
the vote biographer Biden in the five
states where he goes straight up at 3 30
in the morning we all watched it happen
Okay forget about that that's perfectly
normal just like McGuire and Sosa
hitting 70 home runs in a season when
nobody's ever done it before we well no
that there was an anomaly there so but
but see you just you just nailed it
right there 51 intelligence agencies
lying about the Biden laptop lying about
Donald Trump the Russian collusion
narrative that was totally fake the
censorship on the internet that was
driven by Democrat Party policy to argue
that that is not at the very least
election interference to me is just just
being dishonest if the federal
government had puts their finger on the
election if they stick their finger in
if they put their finger on the scales
that means that it's not a fair election
so the whole Co the idea that it's the
most free and fair election it's a lie
it wasn't free and fair the federal
government stuck their nose in the
federal government is not supposed to
have an opinion on who does or does not
have the reins of power it is the people
that make that decision so the fact that
federal government put their their their
finger on the on the scales means that
it's illegitimate it is totally
illegitimate and Joe Biden is an
illegitimate president because cause of
it I don't care who it pisses off this
is true to quote Chuck Schumer you'll
mess around with the intelligence and
they have five ways a Sunday of getting
back at you 100
all right we got Seth weathers
conservative dad's revenge is coming
Google it shout out Seth thanks for the
Super Chat and we're excited for
conservative dad's Revenge I'll pull up
a picture we'll talk about it on the uh
members only but we also have Archie the
Proto says Tim you got a steam deck
congrats on becoming a Linux gamer most
Windows game work on Linux now thanks to
valve except those that require kernel
level anti-cheat your complaints about
wine a couple weeks ago are outdated yes
I stand corrected uh I used to use
Ubuntu for everything but this is this
is a long time ago we would use wine
to run our Windows programs but uh it
has so I got the steam deck I was at I
went to the eye doctor and I was getting
new contacts and as I was waiting there
was a Game Stop next door and I went in
and they had a steam deck which is a
handheld PC gaming device it's awesome
and because PC can play basically all
games with console command XS I was like
that sounds like a really good idea and
it's absolutely fantastic I'm playing
balder's gate on it and I'm probably
gonna I'm probably gonna play all my
games on the steam deck there's no
reason for me to use anything else it's
it's amazing the battery drains real
quick it is what it is but uh I just
plug it in and then I think I might get
like an hour of play time
you know it's like the original Game Boy
you know you didn't get much battery out
of that one either no but now I'm
playing like a 100 gigabyte AAA game
it's awesome so the future is pretty red
it's super light too it's a bit big but
it works really well
and it's touch screen too it's it's I'm
I'm impressed with it man
all right what do we got
tricky hickey says Owen as someone who
has done a couple years myself whatever
you do don't eat the candy bar left on
your bunk that's not a housewarming gift
you two months will fly by good luck
brother and keep fighting the good fight
yikes
uh you know I'm I'm still hoping I'm
still hoping uh that I do not get
incarcerated we're still we're still
fighting that in the courts through the
appeal system and I think anybody who's
honest with themselves would say that
that's not what I deserve yeah well I I
it's it's insane well first
at first they they they you were
protesting in the capital or something
that's what it was like 2019 I think it
was so I was at the and and
I mean look really I think the reason
why they hate me is because
I go to their places and I say the truth
I mean you want to talk about speaking
truth to power it's not Maxine Waters
it's Owen Shroyer and we both happen to
be from St Louis but uh it was the 2019
impeachment of Donald Trump
and I stood up and I said this is an
illegitimate impeachment Donald Trump is
innocent it was a 30-second transaction
when the police grabbed me and escorted
me out I didn't fight them at all and I
mean I don't I don't know how deep you
want to go into this but usually with
these cases they will either just walk
you out and and that's that especially
if you don't fight and you're all by
yourself they'll just they'll just say
hey you disrupted and they'll just walk
you out they won't even bother charging
you with anything or they may hit you
with a charge they won't detain you and
you'll either get the case tossed or
you'll have a you know a minor offense
or whatever well with me it was the
extreme and the funny thing was when
when I was sitting here with the police
officers they were like expecting hey
we're just going to walk you out the
door and let you go
and then somebody got on there somebody
got on their walkie-talkie and they had
to hold me and they said oh wait a
second hold on a second somebody said no
you're you're going to detain him and
then when I got arrested for having a
piece of tape over my mouth at the
Capitol that said censored that's a real
story by the way I got arrested in the
U.S Capitol for having a piece of tape
over my mouth that said censored
literally crazy they even put it in the
indictment you can look it up for
yourself
so for this protest they said just don't
do it again basically like supervision
and deferred prosecution yes and I don't
know if you want to get into the to the
depths of the in in the documents here
well maybe we'll get into more detail
with the members only my point is just
what you what what they're accusing you
of doing now by being a restricted
grounds is effectively the same thing
one warranted nothing and one warrants
60 days in prison plus two and a half
years of supervision it's ridiculous
like two and a half years of supervision
is insane for for being on for for the
charge when it's all said and done
um let's say this is how it goes when
it's all said and done
I'll have spent about
62 63 days in jail and about six years
on probation well it's crazy unreal well
if you haven't already everybody smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you do like it and head over to
timcast.com click join us the members
only show will be live on the front page
in a few minutes just click it and you
can watch and hang out and as a member
you can actually submit questions and
call into the show and talk to us and
our guests it's gonna be a lot of fun so
I hope to see you there you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally everywhere follow me on
Instagram
do you want to shout anything out yeah
thank you so much Tim so find me at the
Monica Crowley podcast available on all
podcast platforms check me out there
also on Twitter and true social at
Monica Crowley and on Instagram at
Monica Crowley underscore right on well
if you want to listen to the federal
government's favorite talk show you can
find me at
band.video I'm the host of the Infowars
war room three to six pm Central Time
weekdays also infoware Sunday Night Live
6 to 8 P.M again at band.video find out
why the federal government tunes into my
show every day and the proof is in their
filing document right on I am Phil that
remains on X I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify you can follow us on Apple music
on Pandora on YouTube on Amazon music
you know the internet
I wish you the best with everything my
friend Owen for real thank you and uh
yeah check me out on the internet guys I
might make a friend sir or Myspace just
to like hearken back to Old Times I'm
surge.com we will see you all over at
timcast.com in a couple minutes thanks
for hanging out